and the verified contact information of both survivors
would have been sent to the authorities at the same time
for investigation and follow up.
If a system like this had existed for Hannah and her peers,
it's more likely that they would have reported,
that they would have been believed,
and that Mike would have been kicked off campus,
gone to jail, or at least gotten the help that he needed.
And if we were able to stop repeat offenders like Mike
after just their second assault following a match,
survivors like Hannah would never even be assaulted
in the first place.
We could prevent 59 percent of sexual assaults
just by stopping repeat perpetrators earlier on.
And because we're creating a real deterrent to assault,
for perhaps the first time,
maybe the Mikes of the world would never even try to assault anyone.
The type of system I'm describing,
the type of system that survivors want
is a type of information escrow,
meaning an entity that holds on to information for you
and only releases it to a third party
when certain pre-agreed upon conditions are met,
such as a match.
The application that we built is for college campuses.
But the same type of system could be used in the military
or even the workplace.
We don't have to live in a world
where 99 percent of rapists get away with it.
We can create one
where those who do wrong are held accountable,
where survivors get the support and justice they deserve,
where the authorities get the information they need,
and where there's a real deterrent
to violating the rights of another human being.
Thank you.
(Applause)